[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro sur tv78 de si on parler sport
l'émission ne surtout pas manquer sur
vos écrans ou en podcast si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui il
y aura comme toujours des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur comme toujours
pour m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont
avec nous sur ce plateau ils sont en
pleine forme comme toujours présentation
en musique on commence à ma droite c'est
un véritable combattant il donne
toujours le meilleur de lui-même on le
surnomme dans cette émission le
gladiateur mais on peut aussi l'appeler
le George prounet yvelinois Pierre
Chevalier du Rugby Club de Versailles
est avec nous pendant une heure Bir et
bonheur comment sal salut les amis ravi
d'être là euh et en pleine forme comme
vous l'avez rappelé pour une actualité
je pense très chargée malgré ce temps
mossade sur sur l'Île-de-France et sur
les yelines mais on est prêt mais c'est
bientôt la Saint-Valentin oui ça c'est
vrai et positif et d'ailleurs pour fêter
ça il y a un beau match de foot le même
soir alors on continue à gauche musique
vous reconnaissez sa musique on l'adore
comme un bon plat de pâte carbonara on
l'adore comme une pizza napolitaine on
lève comme un spritz au coucher du
soleil de Sienne notre italien l grgory
canalé est avec nous pendant bonjour
Michel bonjour Pierre bonjour à tous
Comment allez-vous PL carbonara plutôt
pour moi un peu un petit sprit au
coucher du soleil c'est sympatit sprit
c'est toujours sympa au coucher du
soleilise pourquoi pas avec
modération comment allez-vous ça va ça
va très bien ouais là voilà on est dans
le dans le dur de de l'année l'hiver
commence à aller arriver peut-être à son
terme il reste un mois avant le
printemps donc là on est on est vraiment
dans le dur mais on on ne lâche rien et
je sais que vous êtes très content de
l'arrivver de Lewis Hamilton chez
Ferrari bah oui c'est un rêve qui
devient réalité on en parlait depuis un
an au début on y croyait pas pas
vraiment et là ça y est la légende les
deux légendes s'associent même si leous
Hamilton est plutôt sur la fin de sa
carrière on espère pour la Ferrari un
retour au sommet on leur souhaite en
tout cas on repasse de l'autre côté
musie qui nous vient tout droit du
Sud-Ouest il est né à poau c'est un
passionné de rugby c'est un très grand
fan de l'équipe de Nouvelle-Zélande
comme on peut l'entendre c'est sa
deuxème tit
ffilé d'affilé dans cette émission
Nicolas est avec nous pendant une heure
comment allez-vous ben très bien écoutez
on est au lendemain de la fête nationale
de Nouvelle-Zélande le 6 février 1840 et
bien il y a eu la signature d'un accord
entre les Britanniques et les Maoris
c'est ce qui a permis au Maoris d'être
accepté dans cette société
voilà dire on élève un peu le débat dans
cette émission avec Nicolas
d'andrich il y en a besoin effectivement
on termine de l'autre côté musique vous
reconnaissez sa musique c'est un
monument un pilier de cette émission
c'est une vraie star il est aussi
influent que la chanteuse Taylor Swift
les cheveux en moins notre Rostar Jean
Miss ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec
nous pendant une heure comment
allez-vous ça va très bien bonjour à
tous là on va redescendre un peu les
débats puisquon les a élevés on va les
descendre maintenant moi ça va très bien
en plein je sais pas qui c'est la
chanteuse Taylor Swift je sais je je
connais pas tout les je connais les
connais pas
tout je crois que Pierre connais bien et
on verra je connais pas les remplaçag je
voulais juste faire un petit bisou à ma
maman qui se remet d'une opération
importante et on l'embrasse rempli des
stat Taylor Swift comme comme gens ouais
exactement pareil voilà 80000 personne
vous attendre à l'extérieur du studio he
comme Taylor Swift je voir qui c'est qu
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission on va parler des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 la piste de BMX
située à côté du Vélodrome national de
50 ans Livine va être retravaillé les
équipes ont commencé des travaux cette
semaine l'objc objectif est de
transformer la piste pour veiller à
l'équité entre les futures nations
engagées et ne pas privilégier la France
les travaux vont durer pendant les
quatre prochaines semaines alors votre
avis sur ce remodelage qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez pour l'équité on
valide validez pas spécialement Jean
vous
voz partager bon allez on va faire un
petit tour de table alors pourquoi
polémique c'est ça me fait penser à au
choix de l'équipe de de France de rugby
pendant la coupe enfin avant avant et
pendant la Coupe du Monde de 2023 qui
s'est terminé l'an dernier de chois de
ne pas choisir marcousi pour les mêmes
pour les mêmes raisons euh on fait pour
les souciis d'équité voilà souci
d'équité en disant que il faut pas que
le pays haute soit avantagé en
travaillant sur ses propres
installations mais je pense que pour le
rugby comme pour le BMX on doit être les
seuls les seuls pays hautes
organisateurs à opter pour cette cette
phase d'équité alors c'est bien pour la
grandeur d'ame pour l'esprit de pierre
de cbertin très bien très bien pour ça
et la sportivité tout à notre honneur
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on est
vraiment les seuls à le faire et
peut-être les les dindons de la farce en
l'occurrence de ne pas tirer profit de
cet avantage à domicile ça nous coûte
suffisamment cher d'organiser les jeux à
domicile il faut bien qu'on puisse de
temps en
tempsant de remodelage de cette piste de
BMX ça fait beaucoup he ça fait ça fait
un avantage qu'on laisse pour un budget
supplémentaire bon non moi je trouve ça
totalement normal parce que on le voit
sur le ski le ski les pistes sont
remodelées à chaque fois c'est pas la
même le même tracé et tout ça chaque
skieur est mis sur le même pied
d'égalité avec Ben des repérages avant
de avant la compétition moi je trouve ça
normal et puis oui ça ça avantage les
Français oui on est chez nous il faut
bénéficier d'un certain avantage je
pense que le public sera au rendez-vous
pour pousser les athlètes français et
donc bénéficier d'un certain avant il
aura environ 3000 spectateurs autour du
Stadium DX voilà je pense que oui c'est
sûr ça aurait avantagé les Français mais
je trouve que pour une équité sportive
et puis on est sur les Jeux Olympiques
quand même l'équité sportive c'est les
valeurs du sport les Jeux Olympiques
c'est c'est le SOMUM des valeurs du
sport donc oui je pense que c'est c'est
normal que ce soit remodelé pour que
chaque athlète du BMX soit sur un pied
d'égalité au départ greégory on parle
quand même de professionnel je pense
qu'ils avaient le temps aussi les
athlètes étrangers pour venir étud dit
avant cette piste de 50 ans Livine
d'ailleurs au mois d'avril il y aura
alors non pas un Test Event parisque le
public ne sera pas convié mais il y aura
une petite session test pour les les
athlètes qui pourront s'essayer sur
cette nouvelle piste est-ce que dans les
sports collectifs comme le football le
rugby on va changer la pelouse à chaque
fois qu'on accueille un nouvel
adversaire je je ne crois pas al c'est
pas la même chose ouais je je pousse
peut-être un peu le trait mais je force
un peu le trait mais moi je je rejoins
pierre sur le fait qu'on organise les
jeux et bien c'est aussi de bonne guerre
la personne qui organise qui reçoit un
léger avantage peut-être un gros
avantage même sur ses adversaires là où
je rejoins pas forcément Nicolas oui le
public ça peut pousser les les les
athlètes le les spectateurs peuvent
pousser les athlètes ça peut être aussi
une source de stress une source
peut-être de pression de vouloir se
donner face son public après voilà c'est
bonne guerre pour moi quand on est à
domicile on a un léger avantage sur sur
l'adversaire et pour les Français c'est
qu'une fois tout tous les 100 ans pour
les Jeux olympiques d'été Jean qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez alors vous étiez
partagé vous aussi je suis partagé
l'équité sportive oui d'accord ok
l'équité sportive mais quand même ça
c'est purement français c'est vraiment
purement français on est les seuls après
je pense que ce sont des règles ce sont
des règles qui vont un peu plus haut que
la France ça au niveau
international on aurit gardé on aurait
gardé la même piste et puis c'est tout
et puis si cétait pas content c'était
pareil là ça me fait passer exactement
tout à l'heure pierre a parl de la Coupe
du Monde de ri je je je me souviens
celle de 2007 on on est pays
organisateur on est troué le moyen
d'aller jouer notre quart de finale au
pays de gale voilà mais c'est purement
français ça voilà il av été gagné je
crois ce quart de finale oui d'accord
mais fait on met pas toutes les chances
de notre côté alors qu'on est pays
organisateur d'aller jouer une phase
finale un quart de finale la Coupe du
monde à l'extérieur on est quand même il
y a que nous pour faire ça dans le monde
donc là c'est un peu le même principe on
avait on est le pays organisateur on a
certes un petit avantage mais c'est un
peu normal parce que là je j'appuie un
petit peu plus sur ce qu'a dit Pierre
tout à l'heure ça fait quand même de
deux choses négatives on a plus
l'avantage la piste et en plus ça va
nous coûter plus cher donc non je crois
que si c'était pas une obligation si
c'était une obligation d'accord mais si
ce neétait pas c'était pas nécessaire
pour moi Grégor après je disais que
j'étais partagé parce que pour moi le
point positif c'est que cette piste elle
a déjà 10 ans on a peut-être tendance à
l'oublier mais ça fait déjà 10 ans que
ce Stadium de BMX est construit et ça
permet de renouveler un peu un petit peu
l'équipement de lui donner aussi un peu
plus de futur après les j parce qu'on
parle sans C de de l'héritage au moins
avec une piste neuve avec voilà avait
été fait légèrement si mes souvenirs
sont bons 3 4 ans après sa sa
construction parce que la première
descente était trop dangereuse d'accord
ben après voilà trouve que c'est positif
de temps en temps de de changer le
parcours c'est vrai que là juste avant
les J pour les athlètes français qui ont
brillé lors des derniers Mondiaux hein
faut se souvenir qu'on a eu côté
masculin un podium historique avec trois
Français qui étaient sur le podium des
des Mondiaux de de BMX Race bah c'est
vrai que ça ça retire ce petit avantage
après voilà plus d'équité peut-être sont
dans les valeurs des J à 5 mois des J on
peut on peut même se poser la question
de savoir si c'était dans le cahier des
charges ou si si un peu au dernier
moment on a lu un une astérisque qui est
tout au bas au bas au bas du de la Bible
que
quea pas vu voilà et et on est on est à
5 mois des Jeux donc je me pose la
question si c'était prévu de longue date
par souci de sportivité et d'équité
pourquoi le faire aussi tard et est-ce
que ça avantage vraiment sur une
compétition comme le BMX finalement de
refaire la p
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Nicolas après il y a des qui sont fait a
des qui sont faitant il y a quand même
une part de chance quand même dans le
BMX finalement il une part de chance
parce que oui effectivement vous êtes
quatre à partir il peut y avoir des
chutes il peut y avoir une trajectoire
mal prise et qui en qui emmène bah si
c'est comme le ski cross c'est comme le
snowboard cross des disciplines encore
une fois divers et qui peuvent emporter
tout dépend de la trajectoire qui est
pris par l'athlète celui qui est devant
ou celui qui est derrière vous après oui
celui qui part devant et qui maîtrise
bien la piste il a plus de chance
d'arriver au bout parce qu'il peut pas
il n'est pas emporté dans une chute mais
il y a une part de chance mais comme
dans tous les sports enfin donc est-ce
que finalement cette piste change
quelque chose oui pour moi pour moi oui
parce que un circuit quel qu'il soit la
connaissance d'un circuit euh c'est
c'est un avantage parce que forcément
comme comme disait nicolasas il y a les
trajectoires euh et les les les les les
façons d'aborder les virages et quand on
a la connaissance du circuit eu
forcément on est avantagé ça c'est sûr
mais c'est l'esprit chevalresque
français ça c'est c'est tout c'est tout
nousant dans le BMX Nicolas l'a rappelé
on n'est pas à l'abri de chute ça arrive
souvent et les Français on ont fait la M
expérience lors des derniers Jeux
Olympiques où on avait tris trois
Français en finale il y a eu des chutes
au final personne sur le podium donc
c'est vrai que de ce côtél ils sont 7 à
partir au départ
d' et Z0 sur zé sur le podium zé sur le
podium finalement alors qu'il y avait
trois Français qui étaient en finale
donc si je comprends bien il y a quand
même l'équité quand même respectée du
coup si on fait la piste Jean ouais ou
ou éti partagé je pense qu'on a pas
remis en doute l'équité c'est plutôt le
fait de voilà on est à domicile et c'est
normal que les Français aent un légè
avantage ça c'est sûr que l'équipe des
sportif on pas d'accord pas
d'cord alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler
d'arbitrage le match entre ivri et
versaill en coupe gambardel a été arrêté
suite à des incident avec l'arbitre on
parlera aussi de basket et des
confessions de l'ivelinois Victor
wembanama il parle notamment de son
intégration à la NBA mais avant de
parler de ces thèmes on va parler du
[Musique]
PSG on va parler d'un sujet brûlant
celui de la possible arrivée du PSG à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline avec un stade
de 60000 places les politiques
commencent à en parler la présidente de
la région ilî- de France Valérie pcrè a
notamment dit que c'était un nom pour le
PSG sur l'île de loisir de 50 ans en
Livine elle dit que le PSG doit rester
au Parc des Princes de son côté la
mairie de Paris avec Anne Hidalgo ne
veut pas entendre parler d'une vente du
Parc des Princes elle a dit je le redis
aussi aujourd'hui et une bonne fois pour
toutes il n'y aura pas de vente du Parc
des Princes c'est le patrimoine des
parisiennes et des Parisiens le sujet
est clos on est donc dans une impasse le
PSG veut acheter le parc mais ce n'est
pas possible les dirigeants pourraient
donc décider de partir est-ce que les
propos d'anidalgo sont une chance pour
Saint-Quentin en Eveline oui ou non non
pour
vouscol gr canal oui pour vous fa un
petit duel entre allez Jean et Nicolas
d'endr
expriag pasit parler
l'expérience à vous donc qu'est-ce que
j'ai
dit estce que prop sont une chance pour
libine oui et vous avez répondu oui oui
c'est une chancee parce qu'il est
certain que si elle reste ferme comme
elle l'a bien dit sur son communiqué il
n'y aura pas de vente du parc des prines
et on sait que les Qataris veulent
veulent développer le l'image du PSG qui
est déjà bien bien développé et et que
le fait de ne pas pouvoir acheter le par
des princes les les bar donc ça c'est
certain donc s'ils ne peuvent pas et
s'il y a un veto forcément ils vont ils
veulent ils veulent se se se se se
diriger vers une autre solution qui est
le stade à 5 et ivelines et qui c'est
qui serait une bonne chose pour les
ivlines c'est sûr c'est certain et puis
en plus ça ferait encore un deuxème un
deuxème endroit un deuxème camp du PSG
dans les ivelines sur les terres des
ivelines donc là ce serait même plus le
PSG qu ce serait ce serait plutôt le le
le le le Saint-Germain Football Club
50 ans eniveline 50
an- 5 catar
enatar c'est pas mal MLB aussi le Montin
de Breton que vous répondez Nicolas j'y
crois pas du tout parce que alors certes
le Parc des Princes et le patri fait
partie du patrimoine des Parisiens et
des Parisiennes mais le PSG fait partie
du patrimoine des Parisiens et des
Parisiennes si vous envoyez le PSG à
Saint-Quentin en yeline ça veut dire que
sur Paris et bien il y a plus de PSG
alors à quoi bon conserver le nom
PSG deuxième chose je rappelle que ça un
impact économique assez important pour
Paris le parisag-germain c'est un na pas
une source d'attractivité économique et
touristique il y a des touristes qui
viennent uniquement à Paris pour voir le
Parc des Princes pour aller à la
boutique du PSG alors si vous envoyez le
PSG dans les divines à quoi bon
conserver le nom PSG et il y a plus de
lien avec Paris et puis la troisème
chose j'ai fait le tour un peu de
l'Europe pour voir où sont situés les
stades des grands d'Europe quand je vous
ai dit he qu'il estlevé un peu le et
quand vous regardez et quand et quand
vous regardez les stades euh Madrid San
diago bernabéou j'ai pris le centre de
chaque ville j'ai taper sur Google Map
voilà Madrid Santiago bernabéou c'est 7
km j'ai Fri Amsterdam le stadionancuf 8
km et là on est à 25 km entre le Parc
des Princes et l'île de loisir c'est un
peu loin le seul équivalent c'est Lyon
avec l'ancien stade Gerland et le parc
OL on est à 22 km de distance entre les
deux stades mais on reste dans la
banlieue lyonnaise le seul stade
qui n'est plus rattaché à la ville c'est
à Lille le stade Pierre MAOI qui est à
ville neuf d'Asque et non pas dans l'île
intramuros on n pas sur un grand Europe
mais c'est un autre exemple de stade qui
n'est pas situé dans la ville du club et
bien c'est c'est villeendasque avec le
stade pierreem à Lille voilà qui vous a
convaincu grégoryi on donnera ensuite la
parole à Pierre moi je disais oui c'est
une chance pour 50 ans niin ces proposil
dalgo parce que de la même manière que
que le disait gens on est dans une
impasse aujourd'hui il y a une ville de
Paris qui dit ouvertement on ne vendra
pas le Parc des Princes c'est un
patrimoine des Parisiens des Parisiennes
de l'autre côté on a naserel rifi le
président du parissgermain qui souhaite
avoir un stade être propriétaire de son
stade ça c'est ça a toujours été dit
même dès qu'il est arrivé au club il
avait pensé racheter le Parc des Princes
pouvoir l'agrandir à l'époque on parlait
de de pouvoir agrandir le Parc des
Princes c'est assez compliqué de pouvoir
l'agrandir on va dire dans les les
stands standard que souhaite le le parc
le le PSG puisque on veut un stade de
60000 places avec ce périphérique qui
passe en dessous du du Parc des Princes
actuellement c'est un peu compliqué de
pouvoir aller jusqu'à cette jauge de
60000 places donc soit il rachète le
parc pour faire des travaux d'envergure
comme il le souhaite soit ils vont
construire ailleurs parce que ils
veulent ce stade de de propriété ils
veulent aussi développer une expérience
commerciale tout autour du parc des
prince avoir une boutique du PSG
pourquoi pas un centre commercial un peu
plus établi pe plus impactant aussi pour
pour la marque parissgermain donc moi je
vois mal comment on peut aller devant
dans dans ce dossier avec deux personnes
anidalgo et naserl RFI qui ne selon Le
Parisien ne se parle plus depuis un an
et demi moi j'ai du mal à avoir une
issue dans ce dossier peut-être que
l'issue c'est dans dans dans désormais 2
ans maintenant à la ville de Paris une
alternance il y a l'opposition de droite
qui commence à dire que elle n'est pas
opposée à une une vente du Parc des
Princes au au paris-sint-germain et
l'affaire devient politique finalement
donc l'affaire devient politique donc à
voir ce qui pourrait arriver mais je
vois mal le PSG confirmer le le bail qui
va jusqu'en 2044 ils sont locataires
exclusif du du Parc des Princes je vois
mal le PSG continuer dans cette
situation dans dans ce parc des Princes
Pierre Chevalier moi à la question
simple est-ce une chance pour 50 Ansel
j'ai répondu oui donc je je suis je suis
du côté de jeens maintenant du principe
général sur ce dossierl d'accord avec
avec Nicolas sur la partie patrimoniale
parce que je crois que grosso modo on
tourne depuis 3 4 ans aour de autour de
gros sous et de patrimoine personne
actuellement n'a le choix dans la date
sur la période de négociation et sur le
la possibilité d'aboutir dernièrement
sorti de Pierre Rabadan qui dit on fera
tout pour investir au côté du PSG mais
on éviter mais tant qu'il y a pas de
session donc là confirmation de ce que
dit de ce que dit sa mère
mire et derrière on a je pense des coups
de bluff successifs pour se remettre à
la table et arriver infin à un à un
stade qui est qui serait propriété du
PSG pour ncer et le garder pour le
patrimoine des Parisiens et des
Parisiennes je vois pas ce qu'elle
voudrait en faire aussi de l'autre côté
pour si la si la si la ville de Paris
voulez voulez le le garder qui mettre si
le PSG n'est pas là si le PSG quitte le
Parc des Princes 50 an ou ailleurs
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'il advient de ça
on avait déjà parlé en plus petit comité
tous les trois il y a 15 jours en disant
que il y a il y a jamboin qui est pour
le rugby à 10 m il a a il est
inexploitable en l'état et au au final
le Qatar veut simplement un montant
d'investissement pour agrandir pour
faire des Loges dignes de ce nom et pour
avoir pour avoir un retour sur
investissement aussi par rapport à tous
les tous les dollars qu'ils ont mis
depuis leur arrivée à Paris donc
conclusion oui ça serait une chance pour
n'importe quelle ville qui accueillerait
et qui aurait la capacité d'accueillir
un stade un stade pour le pour le PSG
dans les evelines ça serait le deuxème
le deuxè centre le deuxème centre
sportif pour le PSG donc là là on
bascule sur EV Evelin Saint-Germain et
même plus Saint-Germain plus oui si on
veut mais le parisgermain c'est la
culture de Paris c'est la culture des
Parisiens c'est downtown Center c'est
porortes d'ôuteuil et là pour le coup il
y aurait il y aurait quand même un
certain nombre de de doute à lever si si
le le parc si le PSG quittait le parc on
dit dans l'orette que le FC versaill
serait peut-être intéressé par le Parc
des Princes en cas de départ son gr en
cas de départ parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'ils sont obligés de jouer à jamboin
en face les ro che Nicolas dendr un mot
sur l'affaire qui deviendrait politique
elle est déjà politique on en parlait
avec Pierre il y a de semaines dans
cette même émission aujourd'hui
annidalgo elle a sa position
annidalgo maire socialiste de l'autre
côté vous avez Valérie pcrè et hier
Hotman nasrou chez nos confrères de BFM
Paris qui s'oppose en fait au départ du
parissgermain du Parc des Princes c'est
c'est clairement politique aujourd'hui
vous avez la droite et la gauche de la
région parisienne qui se dispute sur ce
dossier et puis bah qui défendent qui
défendent leur position tout ça pour des
enjeux
politique puis voilà clairement c'est
politique et puis vous avez 50 ans en
Yveline qui pour son attractivité
territoriale oui aimerait bien
évidemment voir le parissgermain arver
sur Saint-Quentin en yelin pour une
attractivité territoriale à la fois
économique et puis touristique aussi
bien évidemment ça déplacerait le
parisgermain après est-ce que viendrait
jus voà c'est la question c'est ce que
je disais c'est ce que je disais à à
Pierre et à Grégory il y a de semaines
c'est est-ce que aujourd'hui les ultras
les supporters parisiens vont accepter
ça je pense pas parce que les ultras
sont font partie aussi de ce patrimoine
symbolique de Paris et ils n'accepteront
pas de
venir et parcourir 25 km pour venir à
saqutin que vous avez des supporters
aussi dans lesin bien évidment mais
c'est plus Paris fonctionne plutôt bien
Lyon finalement avec deses vous êtes
dans une vous êtes dans la banlieue
lyonnaise et puis Lyon j'ai pris le
stade gerl au parc mais le parc ne doit
pas être si loin du centreeville de Lyon
les infrastructures just dire que
annidalgo dans ses propos elle a aussi
laissé une petite porte ouverte elle a
dit qu'elle était prête à étudier de
possible transformation du Parc des
Princes sans le vendre mais ce serittir
et d'investir exactement c'est ce que pi
peut-être aussi avec le voilà peut-être
aussi avec le PSG qui pait aussi pour
trans en optant pour un bail
enhitéotique le plus long possible à 99
ans par exemple qui permettrait
d'amortir une partie des des
investissement mais si le si c'est le
PSG qui le fait il ils ont besoin de la
propriété pour pour être plus plus
serein financièrement et sur sur
l'amortissement quand on regarde les
chiffres le Parc des Princes c'est
aujourd'hui
48583 places exactement ils veulent un
stade de 60000 places ça fait un
différentiel d'à peu près 12000 places
est-ce que il y a beaucoup de débat
autour de ce de ce stade est-ce que
finalement c'est c'est pas survendu ce
ce débat à Gent quand on voit que c'est
pour 12000 places supplémentaires oui
mais c'est important 12000 places quand
même
entre par que là il y a pas que le
nombre de places il y a aussi le
standing au niveau des
Loges voilà il veut il y a pas que que
augmenter le nombre de place mais après
si s'ils disent qu'ils veulent passer à
60 c'est que c'est réalisable parce que
sinon ce serait de l'utopie donc non
c'est c'est et c'est lié au sujet
suivant c'est lié au sujet suivant à
notre sujet suivant parce que évidemment
faut le remplir ce stade remplir
justement vous me faites une belle
transition Pier chevalier vous faites de
la télé depuis quelques temps on va
continuer à parler du PSG ou plutôt d'un
joueur du PSG il est libre de s'engager
où il veut la saison prochaine depuis le
1er janvier il agite déjà le mercato je
veux bien sûr parler de Kylian Mbappé à
25 ans le buteur et capitaine de
l'équipe de France semble enfin décidé à
quitter le club de la capitale le natif
de Bondi formé en partie dans les ivines
à Clairefontaine voudrait rejoindre le
club de ses rêves le Real Madrid 14 sois
vainqueur de la Ligue des Champions mais
le PSG espère encore le faire changer
d'avis la question à 1 million de
dollars fait-il le bon choix s'il part
au Real Madrid oui ou
non oui pour vous Grégory canalé oui
pour vous Jean oui pour vous pierre et
vous êtes partagé Nicolas vous êtes en
désaccord avec tout le monde aujourd'hui
tout dépend du point de vue en fait vous
allez bien oui très très bien très très
bien allez-y c'est le côté néozélandais
je suis à l'heure
néozélandaise non ben ça dépend du point
de vue du point de vue de la carrière de
Kyan Mbappé bien évidemment il faut
qu'il aille au Real de Madrid pour
progresser prendre un autre élan dans sa
carrière après pour le PSG non non parce
que Kyan Mbappé est le meilleur buteur
de Ligue 1 à l'heure actuelle avec 20
buts on sait qu'il impacte fortement le
jeu des parisiens il a toujours pas
gagné la Ligue des Champions avec le PSG
donc on va voir cette année peut-être
pourquoi pas il arrivve en 2017 il a 25
ans il a il peut encore continuer au PSG
puis le PSG un chiffre sur alors bien
évidemment à prendre avec du recul parce
que il y a Messi et Neymar sur la même
période qui sont au PSG entre 2017 et
2023 l'évolution du chiffre d'affair du
parisint-germain il est passé de 503
millions d'euros à
670 670 millions d'euros en 2023 donc on
voit qu'il y a aussi un enjeu économique
ce que disait pierre il y a un enjeu
économique énorme sur ce départ d'
Mbappé du parissintgermain donc ça
serait pas bien pour le PSG après pour
Kyan Mbappé bien évidemment c'est ou
question c'est sur Kilien
Mbappé fait-il le bon choix s'il part au
Real Madrid oui oui oui alors moi je me
suis déjà exprimé sur le sujet il y a
quelques semaines dans le SOP on était
frustré tous de voir qu'an Mbappé
terminer la 3è place du Ballon d'Or
aujourd'hui kan Mbappé pour espérer
remporter le Ballon d'Or bah il doit
mettre un triplet en finale de de la
Coupe du monde alors une coupe du monde
c'est tous les 4 ans c'est pas avec le
PSG à mon sens qu' va pouvoir enfin
l'année ce ce ce titre en plus de ce
titre individuel on attend aussi qu'il
puisse remporter sa première Ligue des
Champions il a brillé dans des campagnes
européennes ça voilà il y a pas en
douter avec Monaco avec le PSG aussi sur
l'édition un peu un peu bizarre du covid
où il y avait eu ce final he maintenant
s'il veut figurer définitivement parmi
les grandseurope si ce is au niveau des
grands ben il doit quitter le le
parissgermain pour le Real Madrid
aujourd'hui au Real Madrid on a une
équipe qui est en train train de se
construire vraiment très intéressante
alors oui le Real Madrid qui sont à
l'écran il y a Bellingham qui a rejoint
le Real Madrid alors il est pas
attaquant mais il met énormément de buts
il y a vintius junior il y a Rodrigo
voilà toutes ces stars du côté du Real
Madrid qui pourrait entourer Kilian
Mbappé on sait qu'il a boudé cette
saison aussi du côté du parissgermain
parce qu'il était pas forcément
entièrement satisfait du rendement de de
ses coéquipiers là c'est la dernière
chance ou jamais de remporter la Ligue
des Champions j'ai du mal à voir quand
même le le PSG remportter la Ligue des
champions cette année vu comment ils ont
galéré sur le premier tour mais après
peut-être que je me trompe he là il y a
une deuxème phase et une deuxième
compétition qui comm vos talents en
pronostiquegor miseer une petite pièce
he sur le PSG j'avais misé cner sur
l'Open d'Australie je tiens dire et
j'avais un premier un premier bon
pronostic nonêtre Meille en 2024 d'un
point de vue sportif on l'espère d'un
point de vue sportif il a tout à gagné à
quitter le PSG et moi en tant
qu'amoureux du sport ce cette photo de
de Mbappé gamin qui circule un petit peu
sur tous les réseaux on le voit avec le
maillot de Cristiano Ronaldo avec ce
maillot du Real Madrid et il rêvait de
ce club quand il quand il est quand il
était petit juste pour le côté allez
amour du sport j'aimerais voir bah son
rêve pouvoir se réaliser c'est-à-dire
rejoindre le le Real Madrid un club dont
il rêvait quand il était petit vous
aimez le bonheur des gens bonheur des
gens j'aim c'est magnifique j'aime la
passion dans le sport Jean qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous alors on parle
sportivement pour le joueur pour qu'il
ait la Mbappé donc je rappelle he il a
25 ans il est au PSG depuis 7 ans 25 ans
25 ans il a plus rien à prouvé au PSG il
a il a tout il a tout montré il a montré
toute tout son talent il n plus rien à
prouvver maintenant pour lui perso sa
carrière sportive et son épanouissement
et et et pour prendre un petit peu plus
d'envergure il faut qu'il parte et le
club le club le club rêvé on va dire
c'est quand même le Real c'est un club
qui fait toujours rêver tous les grands
joueurs de football le rêve de jouer au
Real je le pense la preuve il de dire
c'était son rêve d'enfant donc il va
réaliser et non seulement pour réaliser
son rêve mais en plus sportivement ça va
ça va lui permettre de voir autre chose
et d'évoluer certainement parce que de
montrer autre chose au PSG il a plus
rien à prouvver il a plus rien on sait
que c'est un grand joueur il a tout fait
pour le PSG s'il y en a un qui a pas
triché au PSG c'est bien lui on a parlé
tout à l'heure de de de de de Neymar ou
ne parlons même que Neymar lui lui au
niveau des tricheurs et voilà alors que
clian Mbappé c'est un garçon qui a tout
donné pour le PSG aujourd'hui il a 25
ans il faut qu'il parte et que de mieux
que le Real donc je dis bravo on parle
pas du club bien sûr que le club perdre
un Kilian Mbappé ça va être une énorme
perte Lig ai une énorme perte même même
le football français le football le
championnat de la Ligue 1 ça ça va être
une perte parce que ne plus avoir ce
joueur dans notre championnat en plus on
renégocie les droits télé en ce moment
pour la Ligue 1 oui cou va prendre un
coup là on risque prendre un coup a
priori sans Mbappé on a déjà une décote
de 20 % de la Ligue 1 et Mbappé seul
Mbappé voilà tout seul représente 140
millions d'euros par an qui sont générés
pour la Ligue 1 donc c'est déjà ce
serait ça au
moins chifres écom côté économique après
on parle du sportif là est-ce qu'on peut
lutter contre un rêve non non il faut
les poursuivre il faut aller au bout
donc la question fait-il le bon choix
comme comme Greg oui il fait le bon
choix c'est le choix qui s'impose c'est
le choix dont il rêve depuis depuis tout
gamin nous on se consolera comme on peut
avec l'équipe de France parce que on
perd on perd Kyan Mbappé sur la Ligue 1
le parc le parc qu'on ne remplira plus
de la même manière sans qu'il ait un
Mbappé va le pleurer va le pleurer ça
c'est s à quoi ça sert de construire un
St de 60000 places du coup non mais
c'est une vraie question ça c'est une
vraie question parce que
l'attractivité a il y en aura d'autres
mais l'attractivité du PSG depuis ces
dernières saisons sans qu' kan Mbappé
c'est c'est c'est la la politique de la
chaise vide he donc donc c'est c'est un
un vrai sujet effectivement pour les
investissements du PSG c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'ils font le forcing pour
qu'il reste et je pense qu' enfin ce
qu'il se dit c'est qu'il serait capable
même de refuser une proposition qu'on ne
peut pas refuser au PSG c'estàd d'aller
au moins 10 ans au Real qui est déjà une
belle une belle proposition par qu'on
parle de 400 millions 400 millions la
saison mais je crois aussi que sport
pour pour compléter ce qui ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est que un un Carlo
Ancelotti est plus est plus expérimenté
qu'un luouis Enrique à ce stade là pour
aller chercher les trophées qui lui
manquent Ligue des Champions Ballon d'Or
donc c'est c'est le choix qui s'impose
c'est son rêve en plus mais écoutez il
nous fait rêver nous donc laissons lui
les siens dernière question sur Kyan
Mbappé les pourcentages je faire un
petit tour de table les pourcentages de
chance de voir Kyan Mbappé au Real parce
que ce n'est pas encore sûr et certain
qu'il y aille pourcentage chance V
pronostiquer bah étant donné que son
contrat arrivve à échéance il y avait
quand même une année en option mais il
l'a pas saisi l'année en option devait
se négocier l'été dernier ça pas été
relevé le contrat arrivve à échéance cet
été donc on est quand même sur du allez
8020 pour moi 80 % de chance de voir
Kyan Mbappé partir ouais 90 90 pour
Bouan pour le Real ou partir partir
au a ah 70 30 je rajouterai juste si il
reste au PSG c'est un choix économique
si il part c'est un choix sportif ça
c'est beau ça pierre 100 % il part et
real real
90 ça c'est ça est enregistré on verra
ça dans dans les prochaines semaines on
suivra ce dossier en tout cas avec
attention on va maintenant parler d'un
autre prodige lui fait du basket il
mesure 2 m 23 et il joue en NBA je veux
bien sûr parler de Victor wembaniama le
joueur de 20 ans originaire du
chéneroancour est revenu sur ses
premiers mois en NBA il a dit je cite
chez nos confrères d'ermc tout m'a
surpris et il y a des choses qui
continuent de me surprendre le plus dur
ce n'est pas physiquement mais
mentalement d'aller sur le terrain
chaque soir et de se battre pour
l'équipe parce que les gens en face
veulent te tuer ou dunker sur toi alors
on a l'impression que Victor Wanyama est
déjà le joueur à contrôler sur le
terrain auprès de ses les joueurs ciblé
par les adversaires comme un Bron James
ou un Stephen Curry Greg Popovic ne
voulait pas lancer forcément dans le
grand bain tout de suite mais il a été
un petit peu obligé par la force des
choses la question sur cette thématique
Victor wembanama a-t-il besoin d'être
plus protégé
messieurs non non pour vous Nicolas non
pour vous Jean
pourquoi tout simplement le petit
nouveau quand même ou c'est le petit
nouveau mais c'est pas c'est pas l'île
aux enfants c'est la donc le petit
nouveau le petit nouveau il est parti
là-bas justement pour exploser et il
c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire on
va pas on va pas en faire on va pas le
remettre dans du coton il a 20 ans
maintenant il explose tous les tous les
compteurs au niveau au niveau des
performances et ça va devenir un grand
on est sûr maintenant que ça va devenir
un grand donc forcément dans la mesure
où c'est où où c'est un grand joueur ben
c'est l'homme à battre donc forcément il
va avoir il va il va il va avoir des
contrats sur lui donc donc non il faut
pas le protéger il faut le laisser
grandir le laisser évoluer et surtout le
laisser continuer à performer comme il
le fait il se plaint pas en tout cas
c'est juste un constat je pense pas
parce que il est il est très bien très
bien équilibré dans sa tête et je j'ai
pas d'inquiétude pour lui Pierre c'est
l'heure du bilan en ce moment on est à
mi-saison et justement il y a il y a eu
pas mal de papiers qui sont sortis
récemment notamment une interview de
Greg Popovic sur le sur le le cas Victor
qui suit finalement depuis très
longtemps puisqu'il avait échangé en son
temps avec Vincent Collet qui l' qu' l'a
qu' l'a entraîné au mets et ce qui est
ce qui est étonnant c'est c'est que que
qu'un entraîneur comme Popovic très
expérimenté 28 saisons de NBA dise en
plus ce jour est talentueux et en plus
il est intelligent et il écoute et
Popovic est en train de le façonner
comme il l'a fait avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'autres joueurs qu'il citait
en référence comme Tim Duncan et et Tony
Parker évidemment au Spurs donc le
protéger le le Victor a priori pas
besoin il a il a l'armoire il a la
caisse qui qu' faut il continue
peut-être même encore à grandir il a
pris du il a pris du physique il sait
qu'il est ciblé et il sait que il a même
dit lui que que que les joueurs sur le
parquet veulent lui faire mal ils jouent
tous les deux jours tous les deux jours
ou quasiment même presque tous les jours
sur certaines périodes ils en sont à ils
en sont à la moitié de la saison et il
est toujours à affoler les compteurs
avec 20 points de moyen fait 44 matchs
en 101 jours
donc tous les deux jours en gros 20
points 10 10 rebonds il y a trois blocs
de moyenne et trois passes c'est ça
exactement donc un un s'en fiche je
tiens préciser conit tout tête un rookie
comme ça déjà pour la France c'est c'est
totalement inespéré et et ben un peu
comme comme Kyan Mbappé dont on vient de
parler c'est ce sont des trésors
nationaux il a pas besoin il a pas
besoin de d'être plus mis dans la wat
parce qu'il est il est intelligent il
est talentueux il est grand il est
polyvalent parce qu'il continue à
shooter et à s'entraîner à 3
points couvé par par Popovic et mine de
rien par un projet Spurs qui va qui va
l'emmener petit à petit avec les les
vieux les vieux rooky et les vieux de la
draft vers les sommets rappelle Jordan a
mis 7 ans cette saison avant de gagner
son premier titre on est largement dans
les temps grgor pas besoin de le
protéger effectivement bah on a allant
en choisissant d'aller très vite en NBA
il n a pas eu le choix dans la date sur
la sélection Spurs mais en tout cas on
l'a vu cette année évolué en NBA dans
une équipe des Spurs qui voilà
collectivement n'est pas forcément au
beau fix donc 10 victoires pour les
Spurs et 40 défaites depuis le début de
la sison bon il s'expose et forcément
bah voilà quand quand on voit une une
telle telle machine marketing arrivé sur
sur ce championnat de de nbaah les
adversaires ont peu envie de se se payer
sa tête he si je puis dire quand quand
voilà ils veulent dunker sur sa tête
c'est un challeng il ve voilà c'est ça
et du coup est-ce que il faut le
protéger non il a il a fait ce choix
aussi et il veut il veut continuer dans
dans cette carrière il faut qu'il
s'endurcisse et nous on a pas besoin de
le protéger Greg Popovic le fait assez
bien il le couve effectivement il y a
ces 44 matchs joués je sais qu'il y a
toujours une petite frustration et
Victor waniama l'a déjà dit dans dans
les médias sur le temps de jeu effectif
par match il aimerait jouer davantage
euh donc Greg Popovic s'en charge de de
le protéger donc c'est pas à nous de le
faire enfin en tout cas c'est pas au
autes aux autres joueurs de la NBA de le
faire Nicolas oui je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce qui s'est dit en plus
il doit être protégé par son entraîneur
mais je pense qu'il a un cadre familial
aussi des parents qui sont très proches
de lui donc je pense que il a tout ce
qu'il faut pour pour être il est déjà
protégé même mentalement on sait que
c'est un enjeu aujourd'hui assez
important euh le la santé mentale des
sportifs je pense que mentalement c'est
un sujet qui doit être bien pris en
compte aussi il a un préparateur mental
d'ailleurs et un hypnotiseur aussi voilà
ça se développe alors ça c'est c'est de
bonnes nouvelles parce que aujourd'hui
la santé mentale je je le répète est un
enjeu important on le voit dans le rugby
notamment au niveau sportif et des
sportifs professionnel faut savoir que
10 victoires pour les Spurs c'est 10
victoires où Victor wanama était sur le
terrain
donc VO s'il est pas là il gagne pas
voilà ben c'est une réalité en tout cas
dans les statistiques c'est que il
contribue à la victoire des SP je pense
que mentalement ça doit être difficile
au niveau collectif parce que
effectivement 15e dernier de la
conférence West avec vous l'avez dit 40
défaites en 50 matchs donc oui ça doit
être mentalement dur mais je pense que
pour Victor wayama cette saison c'est la
saison de l'apprentissage il faut que ce
soit dur il faut qu'il se frotte au plus
grand et au au au leader de de la NBA
pour qu'il apprenne et je pense que ça
peut lui faire de bien de de se prendre
quelques quelques tartines comme diraent
gens euh quelques tartines pour
apprendre parce que la NBA c'est dur
physiquement et mentalement mais il a
dit que ça va il géit plutôt bien la
preuve que est déjàbut d'histoire avec
la NBA Pierre Chevalier très rapidement
on l'a souvent dit sur ce plateau la
seule chose qui le guête et qui pourrait
le le planter c'est la blessure une
blessure sévère il a déjà eu une petite
alerte à la chfille à la chfille en
milieu de première partie de saison
apparment il disait que c'était pas
forcément une blessure c'était il
faisait attention à sa cheville voilà
ouais il se l''est tendu quand même il
tu àall il a pas de hasard c'est que y a
il y a peut-être une faiblesse au niveau
de cette cheville alors Victor wemanama
va participer à son premier all St game
dans le Rising Star challenge du all St
game à Indianapolis il jouera le 16
février c'est un match entre les
premières et les deuxèes années ceux qui
viennent d'arriver en NBA il va
participer aussi au skills challenge un
concours d'agilité où il faudra shooter
il faudra dribler donc sura ça avec
attention on en parlera sûrement dans un
prochain si on parle sport on passe
maintenant à notre page
[Musique]
débat alors on va maintenant passer à
l'envolé de grégoryi le moment fort de
cette émission voilàvol que dernière
fois j'avais laissé le ou effectivement
effectivement bon en tout cas on vous
laisse carte blanche comme d'habitude
allez-y alors de quoi allez-vous nous
parler je voudrais passer aujourd'hui un
petit coup de gueule un gros coup de
gueule même des actes qui sont
malheureusement devenus trop récurrents
sans prendre à l'arbitre l'insulter le
menacer voir pire l'agresser et le
frapper le 4 février dernier le 16e de
finale de la coupe Gambardella entre
l'US ivri et le Football Club de
Versailles a dû être interrompu alors
que les ivelinois menai de buts à z0ro à
l'extérieur l'un des arbitres assistants
a été la cible de projectile deux
bouteilles d'eau lancées dans le dos et
une balle de tennis reçue alors qu'il
quittait le terrain le ban de versaill a
été également visé par des jets d'eau la
commission de discipline de la
Fédération française de football doit
encore trancher dans ce dossier à
l'heure où je vous parle c'est un éemme
incident en ce début d'année à la
mi-janvier déjà un arbitre de niveau
régional est agressé et menacé de mort
par un joueur et même par des supporters
on le voit sur ces images c'était lors
d'un match à Sergi Pontoise dans le
département voisin du valdoise les
exemples n'en manquent pas je pourrais
vous en citer bien d'autres ce qui donne
quand même l'impression que l'agression
de l'arbitre est devenue banale ça se
passe le plus souvent dans le football
amateur là ici on parle de football mais
le football professionnel ne montre pas
non plus l'exemple souvenez-vous de
cette scène complètement surréaliste
survenue en décembre dans le championnat
tur où un président de club Noncent des
décision prise pendant une rencontre a
carrément débarqué sur la pelouse pour
assiner un coup de point au visage de
l'arbitre alil oulut Meller qui a été
ensuite roué de coup au sol par
plusieurs personnes fort heureusement on
n est pas encore arrivé là en Ligue 1
mais l'arbitre est régulièrement remise
en questions dans ces choix par les
joueurs les entraîneurs au micro des
médias dont les propos sont entendus par
de nombreux téléspectateurs ce qui
n'arrange pas forcément les choses tout
cela a malheureusement des conséquences
sur le nombre d'arbitres en France les
clubs amateurs ont des difficultés à
avoir dans leurs rang des arbitres
licenciés c'est pourtant une obligation
la tendance était déjà là avant le covid
mais elle s'est accélérée il y a moins
d'arbitres les jeunes recrues qui ont
parfois une vocation sont vite
découragés par l'isolement et le climat
violent ambiant moins de candidats mais
aussi des arbitres qui disent stop la
FFF a perdu du 4500 d'entre eux entre
2016 et 2021 dans 54 % des cas la cause
numéro 1 et leur démotivation et aussi
l'insécurité 1000 arbitres en moins par
an en moyenne les chiffres font froid
dans le dos pour un rôle pourtant
primordial dans le sport on ne touche
pas à l'arbitre c'est le message que je
veux faire passer sans elle sans lui les
rencontres ne pourraient pas se disputer
des weekends sans arbitre ont déjà été
décrétés par certaines ligues pour
protester contre les agressions c'est
déjà un premier pas il faut aller selon
moi plus loin dans les sanctions contre
ces imbéciles qui s'en prennent
violemment à ceux qui officient sur le
terrain aller plus loin aussi dans la
sensibilisation des jeunes sur le sujet
l'arbitre est une personne qui a le
droit de se tromper c'est comme dans la
vie on peut faire des erreurs il peut
arriver que l'on soit contre ces
décisions on a le droit de lui dire mais
avec respect et surtout sans porter
atteinte à son intégrité physique je ne
crois pas que l'arbitre fait un
commentaire quand un joueur loupe une
passe Davis une frappe ou quand le
gardien fait une boulette et pourtant
sur les terrains amateurs j'y suis
souvent le dimanche il y a à redire
l'arbitre c'est un athlète presque comme
les autres lui aussi s'entraîne à
l'instar des joueurs lui aussi se
prépare et et parfois durement pour être
prêt pour les rencontres du weekend elle
aussi lui aussi est un passionné de
sport il mérite il mérite donc notre
respect et comme le disait le célèbre
slogan de cette campagne de recrutement
de la Fédération française de football
dans les années 90 je vous laisse
écouter arbitre de foot on n pas le même
maillot mais on a la même passion on n
pas le même maillot mais on a la même
passion merci Grégor pour cette envolé
Merci à VOUS utile Jean qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de cet envolé magnifique
magnifique un sujet très
sensible parce que il vous qui avez
l'habitude en plus d'être sur le terrain
tout à fait Grégory l'a dit sans
arbitrre et il n'y a pas de rencontre
donc les arbitres sont une obligation au
jeu après moi je vais aussi pousser mon
petit coup de gueule parce que je vais
faire la la la différence entre le
football et le rugby aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui comme toujours d'ailleurs au
rugby un arbitre mais vous voyez même au
Top 14 vous voyez le Top 14 jusqu'à la
plus basse division un arbitre mais
jamais vous verrez un arbitre jamais
vous verrez un arbitre se faire
bousculer ouou encore plus se faire se
se se se faire frapper il y a un respect
de l'arbitre au niveau du rugby pourquoi
parce que j'aime autant vous dire que si
même si vous dites tem baltring euh vous
prenez carton rouge et sanction et vous
vous prenez minimum 4 6 matchs pour
simplement avoir dit avoir dit un mot
déplacé même pas une insulte il y a un
respect de l'arbitre et il y a des
sanctions lourdes qui font que l'arbitre
on y'y touche pas par contre au football
je suis absolument désolé mais comment
voulez-vous qu'en amateur on puisse
respecter et éduquer les joueurs à
respecter l'arbitre lorsqu'on voit à
longueur de temps en ligue li des
joueurs venir à ça de l'arbitre leur
hurler dessus parce qu'ils sont pas
d'accord avec leur décision moi je pense
que là on devrait intervenir la
Fédération devrait intervenir pour
justement arrêter ce genre de
comportement parce que les gens
s'identifient on dit que les les les
c'est normal les jeunes s'identifient
aux grands joueurs au grand au joueurs
professionnels de football et quand il
les voit faire ça excusez-moi mais eux
ils le font ils font aussi ils le font
aussi donc qu'on commence déjà à à le
mettre à le mettre sur un piédestal
l'arbitre on y touche pas il y a pas de
on vient pas lui gueuler dessus là comme
on le voit mais mais c'est inadmissible
ça
inadmissible les joueurs si demain on
prend les mêmes sanctions qui que que
les qui sont prises au rugby vous allez
voir vous allez plus avoir ce genre de
problème il y en aura plus et je ne
comprends pas comment aujourd'hui on n
pas encore franchi le le le le pas et
pris ce genre de mesures pour protéger
l'arbitrage grori et pouri et pourtant
si on va au-delà même des sanctions
sportives les sanctions pénales quand on
agresse un arbitre sont assez lourd ça
va de 3 ans d'emprisonnement ferme ça
peut même monter jusqu'à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement ferme si l'arbitre est
à une infirmité de
manière enfin non pas temporaire
justement de manière durable voilà je
chercher le mot merci mais on a quand
même l'impression que on en reste des
fois à la sanction purement sportive et
qu'il y a pas forcément de suite pénale
on a très peu vu d'agresseurs d'arbitres
condamnés par la justice parce que ils
avaient justement frappé un arbitre donc
il faut pourrait peut-être être un peu
plus sévère aussi dans les dans les
sanctions prononcées d'abord Nicolas
d'endr et ensuite vous Pierre Chevalier
je vais partager la vie de gens mais
attention attention on voit des choses
apparaître dans le rugby notamment lors
de la dernière Coupe du monde le
cyberhcèlement a augmenté par rapport
aux arbitres ben kif qui a été ciblé par
de nombreux supporters français qui
insulté l'arbitre du match France
Afrique sud on parle de l'arbitrage sur
terrain attention oua alors ben je vais
je vais y venir je vir mais benokif a
été menacé de mort plusieurs fois
l'arbitre de la finale a été menacé de
mort aussi par des supporters en
Nouvelle-Zélande donc ça peut-être
vigilance petite vigilance sur le cyber
harcèlement et les menaces fait aux
arbitres dans le monde du rugby et
attention aussi dans le rugby je vois je
commence à voir quelques actions
quelques actes dans le Top 14 où parfois
il y a remise en question alors il y a
pas de violence mais attention soyons
vigilant dans le rugby à ne pas tomber
dans ce qui se passe dans le football
parce que il y a certains joueurs qui
viennent contester les arbitres souvent
les arbitres du Top 14 oui oui oui ou il
pr il prennent minimum pénalité alors
pénalité ù ils se font recadrer tout de
suite par les arbitres parce que mais
attention attention parce que ce genre
de chos on voyait pas on voyait pas le
nombre moi je le vois de plus en plus en
tout cas en Top 14 beaucoup de joueurs
qui viennent contester les décisions de
l'arbitre certes les arbitres sont
encore fermes ça c'est question c'est
une question de génération les joueurs
de savent tout je je refai pas le débat
différence foot rugby par rapport au au
au au respect de l'arbitre ça c'est dans
laadn c'est dans LAN rugby Jano la
rappelé le problème qu'on a là c'est
c'est un rappel au combien utile et
tellement navrant de de regarder ça dans
le sport global et dans le sport amateur
en particulier c'est que c'est un
problème sociétal on a on a deux équipes
là par exemple à ce niveau-là qui jouent
sur un terrain de foot comme elles sont
dans la vie et éventuellement à se à se
chercher et plus et plus si pas
d'affinité à se à se à à se frapper il y
a eu récemment un en régional 3 en Corse
c'était le weekend dernier un match
arrêté à cargz avec une bagarre générale
et le et le le l'entraîneur qui vient
séparer qui se fait sécher et rouer de
coup on on en a plein des exemples comme
ça au niveau amateur et c'est vrai au
niveau professionnel donc là là c'est le
le signal d'alarme il est il est tiré
depuis très très longtemps notamment au
football sur le respect de l'arbitre sur
la la vertu éducative du sport le le
respect des uns et des autres il y a
déjà des premières avancées c'est que
des matchs de garçons sont arbitrés par
des femmes au foot comme au rugby
d'ailleurs ça se passe bien des deux
côtés joseséris il y a il y a peut-être
cette cette C ce respect supplémentaire
en plus quand quand c'est une femme qui
qui arbitre euh peut-être l'esprit
maternel qui joue qui joue et filial
mais on a un vrai vrai problème là et
qui qui va pas s'arranger qui va pas
s'arranger sauf si on si on opte pour
des mesures fortes avec l'exemplarité
des joueurs professionnel en Ligue 1 en
Ligue 2 pour le football pour que ça
ruisselle au niveau amateur mais mais
malheureusement on en aura encore des
tonnes des exemples comme ça parce que
parce que la société se devient parfois
se se radicalise un petit peu devient de
plus en plus violente et le le théâtre
du sport n'est plus suffisamment
protecteur pour éviter euh pour éviter
des des débordements comme cela et je le
rappelle on n pas le même maillot mais
on a la même passion on termine cette
émission voilà exactement on termine
cette émission par du rugby je vous vois
vous réjouir autour de cette table hein
on va parler plus particulièrement de un
rugbyman evelinois le joueur du Stade
Français léobaret il a été appelé en
équipe de France pour remplacer
l'arrière du RCT Melvin Jaminet alors
pour le tournoi desstination et le match
contre l'Irlande le versaill à 21 ans il
est bon avec son club faut-il le
titulariser avec cette équipe de France
oui ou non pas de date pas
de faut-il le
titulariser si possible on va dire si
dans les prochains mois dans les
prochains mois quand même dans les
prochains mois oui oui pour tout le
monde non pour vous Jean vous êtes
partagé alors Jean
pourquoi alors je suis je suis partagé
tout simplement parce que connaissez
bien je le connais pas bien pierre le
connais bien par que c'est un versaillis
je le connais pas bien je ne le connais
pas bien
euh c'est vrai qu'il était dans son club
il fait un bon il fait il fait une bonne
saison déjà la saison dernière il fait
un bon début de saison avec le Stade
Français euh il était dans son club
c'est normal le sélectionneur national
lui donne pas le choix dans la date pour
être sélectionné donc forcément il
l'appelle là parce que il y a une
défection il l'appelle c'est juste c'est
à juste titre parce que il récompense
entre guillemets ses performances à à
travers son club donc là il y a pas de
problème après il y a deux niveaux qui
sont complètement différents il y a le
niveau Top 14 et le niveau international
et aujourd'hui léob Barret est un bon
joueur de Top 14 mais on ne sait pas
encore si ce sera un bon joueur
international donc effectivement il faut
lui donner ça il faut il faudra lui
donner sa chance parce que il faut
savoir si il explose ou pas ça c'est sûr
bien falloir qu'on le voit en réalité et
est dans l'exercice de de de de son
talent là entre guillemets mais là pour
l'instant ben il y est dans le groupe et
je lui souhaite qu'une chose c'est
d'être sélectionné rapidement pour voir
s'il a s'il est capable de franchir le
cap et de de passer d'un bon joueur de
Top 14 à un bon joueur international
Nicolas d'enry je vois que vous avez
marqué quelque chose sur ah rendez-vous
en Argentine parce qu'en fait l'équipe
de France va jouer une tournée d'été en
Argentine à partir du mois de juillet
léob Baret fait partie des potentiels
euh alors il pourra jouer en Argentine
que si le Stade Français n'est pas
qualifié pour les phases finales de Top
14 parce que les joueurs appelés par le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France ce
sont ceux qui ont été éliminés et qui ne
sont pas en phase finale de Top 14 donc
si le Stade Français n'est pas
euh qualifié en Top 14 qui pourrait être
le cas parce que aujourd'hui ils sont
leaders du Top 14 mais s'ils ne sont pas
qualifiés lobaré sera dans le groupe
pour la tournée en Argentine et je peux
je m'engage ici je pense qu'il sera même
titularisé à ce moment-là et connaîtra
sa première sélection en Argentine parce
que Fabien Galtier il le fait depuis
déjà 4 ans il met euh il il différencie
certains joueurs les joueurs premium
ceux qui sont titulaires qui ont joué
qu'on a vu à la Coupe du Monde et les
joueurs à fort potentiel et les joueurs
à fort les ovnis voilà comme on dit les
joueurs à fort potentiel sont souvent
appelés lors des tournées d'été et donc
léobaré en fait partie euh Jean l'a
rappelé il fait une super saison l'année
dernière il fait une très bonne saison
cette année il a inscrit deux essai face
au champion de France le Stade
Toulousain qui avait amené les Antoine
Dupont tomar Ramos il y avait tous les
joueurs alignés certes il revenaient de
la Coupe du monde mais ils étaient là et
Léo Barré a quand même mis deux essais
lors de cette rencontre euh donc voilà
je je pense que je fais ce Paris qui qui
sera en Argentine cette cet été avec
l'équipe de France Pierre Chevalier vous
vous le connaissez très bien oui oui oui
j'ai joué avec son père tout ça et
cetera à versaill ouii on le connaît
bien Léo c'est un un un bon pur produit
versaillais couvé à l'école de rugby et
puis qui a qui est monté petit à petit
vers le Stade Français en en passant par
Massie autre bon club formateur il faut
le reconnaître et il y a deux choses qui
jouent pour lui pour sa titularisation
son expérience en U18 et U20 malgré tout
il a il a quand même il s'est frotté
certes avec des jeunes mais au niveau
international et puis sa polyvalence ça
polyvalence où il est capable de jouer
10 12 ou 15 là il joue plutôt 15 avec et
là c'est c'est 3è 3è élément aussi avec
Laurent Labit qui est arrivé au Stade
Français cette saison qui doit toujours
avoir des connexions avec Fabien Galtier
évidemment côté 15 de France donc il y a
il y a il y a toutes les chances de le
voir prochainement euh
euh prendre sa chance en en
titularisation et et en et au moins sur
une feuille de match peut-être peut-être
en remplaçant d'abord et et de pouvoir
faire plus que dépanner à ce niveau-là
parce que il est il est pétri de talent
et qu'il est polyvalent Grégory est-ce
que c'est un cadeau ou pas aussi d'être
dans cette équipe de France en ce moment
où ça tourne pas super bien depuis
quelques matchs au contraire faut tester
hein bah oui je voilà il faut il faut
tester pour lui bien sûr que c'est un
cadeau de pouvoir peut-être s'exprimer
dans dans cette équipe de France je
pense que tout a été dit moi je vais
ajouter l'angle yvelinois même si on a
on a ajouté l'angle versaillais de voir
un yvelinois pouvoir évoluer dans cette
équipe de France Pourquoi pas alors sans
doute pas pour ce tournoi destination on
sait jamais on Italie l'équipe qui est
peut-être la la plus faible de cette
compétition attention attention on ver
on verra mat attention l'émission
bientôt à son terme vous allez vous
retrouver dans les loges non mais voilà
le pour moi le sport c'est c'est c'est
une forme de mérite et c'est vrai que
sur cette saison la saison dernière il a
déjà été très bon cette saison il a très
bien débuté il a fait parler de lui en
en Coupe d'Europe avec ce cet essai de
80 m inscrit face au le donc voilà on
commence à parler de plus en plus de lui
et je pense que ça pourrait être une
juste récompense de le voir très
prochainement avoir sa chance quand même
avec l'équipe de France lui qui a eu
déjà de l'expérience dans les dans les
équipes de France de jeunes avoir de
l'expérience avec l'équipe une chance
avec l'équipe de France A je pense que
c'est mérité Grégory Nicolas vous allez
pouvoir vous expliquer dans les loges
parce que c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission désolé Nicolas vous voulez
rajouter quel chose très rapidement vous
avez 5 secondes discuter avec lui et
échanger à ce propos focus Stade
Français en plus il a la tête sur les
épaules il est focus Stade Français si
les performances sont là avec le Stade
Français forcément il sera appelé avec
l'équipe de France un peu plus de 10
secondes alors on va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous pose une citation du pilote de
Formule 1 Lewis Hamilton qui va
rejoindre donc Ferrari les enfants
croyez en vos rêves même si c'est
impossible je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78